le froid et la pluie ne les ont pas
découragés deux mille deux cents
coureurs se sont donnés rendez vous ce
dimanche 21 novembre en vallée de
chevreuse pour participer à la route des
quatre châteaux avant dé vous créé en
1999 elle a fait ses premiers pas à
chevreuse elle a commencé et puis la
borne est sûre la 19e édition et donc
c'est une proposition découvrir la
vallée de chevreuse à au travers de ses
châteaux donc château de molière château
de breteuil château de méry dont et
château de coubertin voilà tout un
programme
le parcours de 18,7 km se veut
forestiers les participants emprunte à
la fois des chemins sur terre et sur
route avec au programme des montées des
descentes avec 220 m de dénivelé positif
un tracé qui a l'air d'avoir séduit les
courageux ce dimanche c'est sympa on les
quatre châteaux et des beaux paysages
moi je connais le coin donc c'est une
course que je devais faire au moins une
fois mais je connais la région et
j'adore ça mais non magnifiques courses
et jeux super ambiance tout le monde est
là pour encourager son collègue du
terrain non c'est génial belles
sensations sur le parcours belles
couleurs on est encore des petites
couleurs de tonnes donc c'est
sympathique comme mon camarade au fini
un peu au mental pas trop préparé mais
ça va a belle course pas de sensation et
après deux années puisque la dernière
c'était 2019 donc très contente d'avoir
pu participer en faire assez de courses
abordé avec pas mal de château des beaux
paysages une nouvelle édition de la
route des quatre châteaux devraient être
organisées l'année prochaine les
organisateurs espèrent pouvoir attirer
autant de participants